action rebellion will nicht nur für mehr
klimaschutz demonstrieren die aktivisten
wollen den alltag stören
das heißt seit heute ziviler ungehorsam
und straßenblockaden in berlin aber zum
beispiel auch in anderen städten wie
london oder amsterdam aktivisten ideen
damit muss man schon sagen schritt
weiter als fridays for future treten
deutlich radikaler auf und sie wollen
dass ihr protest ebenso ein bisschen
mehr weh tut und genau darum soll es
heute in unserem live stream gehen
wie weit darf protest für den
klimaschutz eigentlich gehen wenn ihr
fragen habt oder kommentare sind die
natürlich die ganze zeit bekommen und
ich werde die dann diskutieren mit
unserem gesprächsgast heute das ist
luisa neubauer die ist bekannt vor allem
als gesicht von files for future hier in
deutschland heute war sie aber auch bei
extension rebellion dabei konnte nahm
frau neubauer
aber sie haben da heute auch eine rede
gehalten
bei der aktion obwohl es ja keine freude
ist future demo war warum genau ich habe
wieder eingeladen rede zu halten wie ich
auch schon bei pulse of europe
eingeladen wurde eine rede zu halten und
habe das gerne angenommen ich glaube es
war eine gute gelegenheit auch unter
klima aktivisten von einem großen
spektrum über diese krise und über uns
aktion zu sprechen
und wir wollen ja heute noch genauer auf
die form des protestes eingehen und uns
dafür aber erstmal anschauen was denn
heute eigentlich so genau los war in
berlin und das gucken uns jetzt mal an
meiner meinung nach ist es höchste zeit
dass alle menschen davon erfahren in
welcher krise wir stecken nach dem was
die regierung jetzt beschlossen hat dass
sie ihr maßnahmenpaket ihr klima paket
noch irgendwie kürzen wir noch mehr
verwässern
das fühlt sich für mich an wie ein
schlag ins gesicht scheint so dass es
nur noch über zivilen ungehorsam geht in
der öffentlichkeit zu schaffen bzw
die verabschiedung von passenden
notwendigen gesetzen zu erwirken
[Musik]
und das möchte ich weiter besprechen
mittelweser neubauer frau neubauer
extinction rebellion und fiel der future
unterscheiden sich ja nicht so sehr in
dem anliegen worum es geht sondern vor
allem in der form des protests jetzt
wird extinction rebellion ja zum
beispiel kritisiert als zu radikal von
manchen und beifall des verf user finde
ich spannend wurde heute zum beispiel
auch auf der demo dort gesagt wer
dagegen zu brav also hier kommen auch
schon ein paar kommentare rhein bei
youtube und twitter hier sagt zum
beispiel alex ganz klar der protest muss
aber friedrich friedlich bleiben auch
wenn er an grenzen gehen muss christ bei
facebook sieht das ganz anders er sagt
es muss radikal sein anders begreifen
dass eben manche leute nicht wie sehen
sie das
vielleicht gibt es zur einordnung freie
software sei von einem großen
klimagerechtigkeit spektrum vertreten
jetzt nicht direkt die gleichen
forderung ich glaube da müsste man ein
bisschen differenzieren
selbst in berlin habe drei sehr konkrete
forderungen die sich stellen verfügter
hat sechs maß man die aber ja nur auf
deutschland bezogen sind also ich glaube
dann bist du ein bisschen ja das müsste
auseinanderhalten rein was die forderung
betrifft gleichzeitig kann man natürlich
durchaus sagen zweite feature
unterschreiben setzten sich beide ein
für eine eine welt und eine zukunft auf
einem gesunden planeten für eine politik
die sich damit der klimakrise
auseinandersetzt und entsprechend
handelt das schon
ich glaube man müsste noch mal in aller
ausführlichkeit darüber sprechen was für
radikalität verständnis wir haben
radikalität ist was du was irgendwie
waren sich negativ konnotierte
diskursiven gleichzeitig würde ich zum
beispiel denken dass ich radikal finde
was die regierung gerade macht wie
radikal die klimakrise ignoriert und
sich über wissenschaftliche kenntnisse
hinweg satz ich finde es keinesfalls
radikal zum beispiel der future sagt
okay aus protest gehen wir
friedrichstraße und ex in belgien hat
eine andere art des protestes gewählt in
mancherlei hinsicht genügt das jetzt
sozusagen direkt radikales weiß ich
nicht es ist halt eine aktionsform die
deutlich tiefer
ziviler ungehorsam reingeben genau also
im prinzip sagt extra berlin jahr
sie rufen durchaus zu zivilem ungehorsam
auf solange es friedlich bleibt und das
ist ja zum beispiel in wirklich eine
unterscheidung zur feier des verfügt und
hier kommen eben auch kommentare in die
richtung die eben sagen wagen der
protest kann gar nicht radikal genug
sein also es gibt ja auch leute die
sagen das muss viel radikaler werden
während andere hier schreiben sie sehen
das nicht so und dahin zielte auch meine
frage gerade an sie also wie es ihre
meinung da wie weit darf dann der zivile
ungehorsam da gehen
ok also vielleicht sollten sie wieder
ungehorsam ist per definition zumindest
laut einiger autoren und denker und
begründet ist sie will ungehorsam es
erst mal friedlich und gewaltfrei wie
man das jetzt sagen aufteilt und ich
glaube darüber müssen wir uns im klaren
sein dass sie wieder ungehorsam für mich
und für ganz ganz viele andere immer
heißt man bedient sich keiner gewalt
nicht gegen sich selbst nicht gegen
andere nicht gegen sachen und jetzt
müssen wir uns fragen okay wir stehen
für dieser gigantischen krise 30 jahre
wurde mehr oder weniger angesichts aller
bekannter fakten über diese krise kaum
was oder eigentlich gar nichts wirksames
unternommen
was muss passieren und da sagen viele
stimmen genau wie feature eben auch ich
sagen okay wir auch ein massenhafter
proteste
ich sehe die proteste weiter feature
macht die ja auch regeln brechen ganz
bewusst leute gehen nicht zur schule
weil es zum beispiel im deutschen der
schulpflicht terrorisiert praktisch als
einen essenziellen teil in diesem
protest spektrum genau wie eben exakt
berlin die sagen gut wir gehen jetzt
nicht nicht zur schule aber wir rufen zu
zivilen ungehorsam aber gibt es da für
sie irgendwelche grenzen weil bei selbst
innerhalb von exotischen rebellion
beispielsweise gibt es ja da
unterschiedlicher meinung
es gibt zum beispiel fall dass mit
drohnen der flugverkehr gestört werden
sollte wäre das jetzt ein punkt wo sie
sagen ja dass geht mir jetzt zu weit in
richtung gefährdung das finde ich nicht
okay aber straßenblockaden meinetwegen
das ist ja
ziviler ungehorsam das ist okay wenn
staus zum beispiel entstehen ich weiß
nicht finde es ein bisschen eine
merkwürdige frage weil wenn ich darüber
zu urteilen
ich glaube was entscheidend ist bei
zivilem ungehorsam ist vielmehr dass
ziviler ungehorsam immer moralisch
begründet ist dass die menschen die von
der verfassung geschützt sind schützt
wenn der staat ist nicht mehr tut zum
beispiel im falle der klimakrise die wir
uns immer öffentlich ausgetragen und
dient kein partikularinteressen das sind
ganz ganz entscheidende teile des
zivilen ungehorsams und natürlich ist
die idee dass die wieder ungehorsam
disruptive ist und gleichzeitig menschen
nicht menschen nicht mehr als notwendig
blockiert in ihrem leben
das ist aber schwer zu vereinbaren ist
es keine frage ich glaube das ist immer
eine abwägungsfrage sie wieder irgendwo
spielt sich immer zwischen legal und
legitim aus moderner die grenzen gezogen
werden ich glaube dass es überall ich
überhaupt nicht an mir zu entscheiden
das ist eine frage von ortsgruppen von
lokalen akteuren und ich bin überzeugt
ist wie zivilen ungehorsam eben brauchen
in friedlicher und gewaltfrei war okay
ich kann ihnen sagen warum ich sie das
frage weil ja durchaus unterschiede
bestehen zwischen for future was das
genau diesen punkt eben angeht oder weil
es eben gerade diese kritik bei
extinction rebellion gibt dass leute
sagen das ist ihnen zu radikal und sie
haben ja auch ein buch zu klimakrise
geschrieben dass es nächste woche
veröffentlicht wird aber was ich schon
lesen konnte in der ankündigung wahr
dass sie da gefordert haben dass man der
aktuellen situation besonnen begegnen
soll
und das klingt ja nun gar nicht radikal
und deswegen stelle ich in diese frage
gefunden was ist an radikalität ich wir
wenn wir von besonnenheit sprechen und
sagen wir genau das klima klima
aktivismus oder 80 wiederum ist kein
selbstzweck
man muss sich genau überlegen wo setzen
wir in ein kloster strategisch sinnvoll
wie bewegung mobilisieren wir menschen
wir halten wir menschen dabei ziviler
ungehorsam ist nicht willkürlich sondern
was etwas hoch taktisch ist das meinen
wir mit besonnenheit das schließt nicht
per se zivilen ungehorsam auf aber was
wir gerade feststellen ist das ressort
future vor einigen wochen knapp
anderthalb millionen menschen
mobilisieren konnte mit einem sehr
friedlichen sehr ich weiß nich
familienfreundlichen protest
und das eben ein ganz entscheidender
teil ist genau wie aber auch andere
aktionsform und ob man dass man in
berlin kritisiert kann es nachvollziehen
und ich glaube auch es gibt da sehr
viele legitime kritikpunkte für
außenstehende wie erleben aber
gleichzeitig dass sie das sehr
erfolgreich machen was sie machen das
heißt auch da stellt sich die frage ob
es nicht auch akteure wirken wie belgien
die genau das machen was sie machen und
ich glaube wir erleben gerade dass das
eben innerhalb symbiose zusammen
funktioniert das nicht weil future ist
jetzt das sagen besser oder schlechter
oder weniger wichtig oder wichtiger als
rebellion haben das ist eine art ja eine
art spektrum in dem sich die
verschiedenen protesten wieder finden
weiß schon spannend wie das polarisiert
also hier zum beispiel schreibt lothar
bei youtube flughäfen blockieren
beispielsweise macht in seinen augen in
diesem kontext sind und lieber twitter
schreibt dagegen aber blockaden des öpnv
zum klimaschutz wie soll das dazu
beitragen das ist eine kritik ganz klar
natürlich auch an gegen die blockaden
von heute und es gibt ja diese meinung
die habe ich heute auch vielfach in den
sozialen netzwerken gelesen dass dieser
zivile ungehorsam oder diese den weg den
jetzt extinction rebellion einschlägt
auch das was beides verfügte geschafft
hat auch kaputt machen kann eben weil es
eben dazu führt dass die leute die
morgens ihre kinder eine kita bringen
wollen oder zum ihren job fahren wollen
jetzt im stau stehen und sagen warum
jetzt so radikal als man es geht ja auch
anders glauben sie also sehen sie da
gefahren gefahr dass das auch ein
bisschen sich negativ auf die gesamte
debatte auswirken kann
ich glaube es hat an dem punkt
potenziell negative effekte dass wir es
nicht schaffen wegzukommen von der frage
wie kann protest aussehen hin zu der
frage warum protestieren wir eigentlich
egal welcher form
natürlich kann man sich jetzt wie wir
damals über schulschwänzen monate lang
referiert haben in einer einer absolut
in den uralten zuspitzung beinahe jetzt
darin verlieren wie jetzt eben
protestiert oder nicht protestiert aber
die die kernfragen sind doch ganz andere
wie kann es sein dass wir nach japan und
vor allem noch intensiv monaten der
klimabewegung vor einem paket stehen was
den namen nicht verdient wie kann es
sein dass
so viele menschen auf die straße gehen
für eine aufgabe die eigentlich dem
start obliegt und der aber an teilen
seiner verantwortung nicht mehr gerecht
werden möchte ganz genau genommen dabei
die regierung und das klima kabinett all
das finde ich extrem skandalös und ich
glaube da müsste man gerade die
scheinwerferlicht hinstellen dass ich
glaube dass jetzt auch machen bevor wir
richtig loslegen aber tatsächlich wir
wollen heute nicht nur über das wie
sprechen sondern eben auch über das
warum und es gab jetzt viel kritik
klimaschutzgesetz schon von anfang an
und jetzt kam eben ein neuer
referentenentwurf und damit auch neuer
ärger und warum das zeigt pablo de la la
he es sollte der ganz große wurf werden
nach monatelangen diskussionen einige
sich die bundesregierung vor gut zwei
wochen am ende auf ein massnahmenpaket
zum klimaschutz
schon damals hielten es viele für
unzureichend doch der jetzt
veröffentlichte gesetzesentwurf sei noch
schwächer als die ursprünglichen pläne
sagen kritiker es geht vor allem um drei
punkte für 2040 wird kein nationales
ziel zur co2 einsparung mehr definiert
das versprechen deutschland werde bis
2050 keine klimaschädlichen
treibhausgase mehr ausstoßen ist nicht
mehr verbindlich festgeschrieben
und es soll anders als geplant kein
jährliches gutachten des klimarats geben
in dem die wirksamkeit der maßnahmen
überprüft wird
eine kontrolle so die regierung solle es
aber trotzdem geben auf diese
überwachung wird glasklar in dem
klimaschutz gesetz verankert sein und
ansonsten werde ich nicht zulassen dass
wir das verabschieden würde das klima
paket nun weichgespült oder nicht volker
quaschning professoren der hochschule
für wirtschaft und technik in berlin
engagiert sich bei scientists for future
vom verhalten der bundesregierung ist er
nicht überrascht dass ein relatives tor
wo was man in diesem entwurf sieht also
frau merkel hat ja auf der
klimakonferenz versprochen möglichst
2050 klimaneutral zu werden in dem
entwurf bezieht man sich wieder auf alte
papiere wo man 80 prozent einsparung bis
2050 hat was ja viel zu wenig ist um das
pariser klimaschutz abkommen einzuhalten
da bleibt man relativ schwammig und da
sieht man auch dass gar kein interesse
da ist wirklich das pariser
klimaschutzabkommen zu erfüllen ein
vorteil abgeschwächter ziele sei
natürlich dass die leichter zu erreichen
sein
na ja im prinzip ist es ehrlich die
bundesregierung hat mit dem jetzigen
klimaschutzpaket gar keine chance die
ziele für 2020 und 2030 einzuhalten da
braucht man ja gar kein thema für 2040
2050 wollen die auch schon verfehlen
wird
und da ist die sorge wahrscheinlich dass
dann einfach der druck weiter entsteht
und den will man raus nehmen
wie auch immer es dann aussehen wird am
mittwoch so der plan soll das gesetz vom
kabinett beschlossen werden
also frau neubauer lassen sie uns über
diesen entwurf sprechender jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen für protest gesorgt hat
jetzt sagt ja angela merkel wir gerade
gehört im beitrag
na ja so ein verlässlicher überprüfbares
monitoring- kontrollinstrument soll es
doch geben
glauben sie dass oder sagen sie wollen
das noch stärker schwarz auf weiß also
ist der aufschrei von heute jetzt in
dieser form gerechtfertigt oder nicht
ich denke dieser gellende schreie sich
vom 20 september an immer weiter gezogen
hat ist mehr als berechtigt und
notwendig ist bemerkt hatte viele aktive
gerade sagen so halt starb das geht so
nicht was wir heute erfahren haben ich
glaube da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein
nicht jetzt legen wir den tag vor dem
abend zu verurteilen
was dann genau eine bei rauskommt werden
wir sehen aber klar es ist natürlich für
uns alles braucht nicht gebrauchen nicht
zu gebrauchen ist wenn es nicht irgendwo
nieder geschrieben steht
und wenn die bundesregierung sagt ja wir
verfolgen neuerdings ins ziel schadet
einhalten zu wollen
dann zeige ich mich schon sehr jung was
läuft bei euch und das meint auch jetzt
nicht ernst es gibt ja durchaus
unterschiedliche interessensgruppen und
die politik muss ja alle vertreten und
irgendwie mitnehmen und wenn ich hier
mich durch die kommentare clique dann
kommt nämlich zum beispiel auch leute
hier zum beispiel tom der sagt natürlich
jeder darf seine meinung haben auch weil
dies verfügte anhänger aber es gibt eben
auch menschen die das nicht
interessieren muss also mal um
sonnenspektrum sprung zu nennen nun ist
das klimapaket aber doch eigentlich für
fall dass verfügbar und richtiger
schritt in die richtige richtung oder
nee also dass es verkehrt womit
deutschland das paris ein abkommen nicht
einhalten können wird und das ist was
wir fordern
ich glaube auch vielleicht ein bisschen
aufzuräumen klar klimaschutz muss nicht
jeden interessieren weil im idealfall
hält sich die bundesregierung an die
eigenen zielvorgaben und kümmert sich
darum dass menschen hat ihren anderen zu
sorgen im alltag oder whatever
interessen nachgehen können und das wird
aber gerade auf eine katastrophale weil
so einfach übergangen
also diese grundidee und was passiert
ist das ist eine bundesregierung sich
darauf auf gut dass man ja irgendwann
mal irgendwelche ziele versprochen hat
aber nichts daraus lernt dass die
reihenweise verpasst wurden
und auf einmal braucht es halt eben eine
masse die sich auf einen tisch kraft und
sagt nicht mit uns das hat auch nichts
mit einer meinung von weise zu tun
sondern mit einer wissenschaftlichen
feststellung dass wir sagen ja nicht wir
finden jetzt übrigens lieber paket nicht
gut sondern wir sprechen mit der
wissenschaft gesagt wenn diesem thema
cup geht wird es paris abkommen nicht
eingehalten werden können das muss so
derart es muss so drastisch verändert
werden um überhaupt noch in den
ambitionen ausreichend zu sein man kann
nicht mit einer besserung sprechen denn
man muss eigentlich von einer
transformation von einem neuen paket
sprechen gut aber trotzdem ich meinte
dass mit schritt in die richtige
richtung sind ja glaube ich auch aus
ihrer sicht ansätze da was sind denn die
punkte wo sie jetzt sagen würden da muss
man jetzt weiter daran dran drehen also
sollte es jetzt weiter gehen konstruktiv
oder sagen sie nie wir müssen jetzt
richtig auf den tisch hauen und sagen
das muss eigentlich ganz neu von vorne
gedacht werden oder gibt es schon sachen
wo sie sagen na ja da sind jetzt ansätze
und die können wir uns weiterentwickeln
naja nun bis klar zu stellen also so ein
bisschen klimaschutz bringt halt nicht
sein also klimaschutz nicht so eine
sache die macht irgendwie so gut wie du
eben kannst und dann guckt ob du landest
wenn man das ernst meint mit dem
klimaschutz und die klimakrise als die
essentielle krise anerkennt die sie ist
dann muss man sich halt an zielvorgaben
halten den international abgestimmt
werden die wissenschafts konforme sind
und da kannst du nicht mit einem
halbgaren paket ja kommen und sagen
haben die mühe gegeben und gucken was
dabei rumkommt dass es im endeffekt
politikversagen und entspricht nicht der
krisen realität das heißt nein ich
glaube nicht dass man davon sprechen
kann es für uns ein richtiger schritt
ist ein richtiger schritt wäre sich mal
bewusst zu machen okay das ist unsere
verantwortung als nation und wir
probieren jetzt in die wege zu leiten
dass wir unserer verantwortung gerecht
werden dass das ein aufwand ist es
mühsam ist das unbequem ist dass wir
wahnsinnig viel austarieren werden
müssen keine frage aber das ist doch
irgendwie der job einer gewählten
regierung das heißt im endeffekt frage
zurückzukommen ich muss an fast allen
punkten
massivst was verändern und was wir
erfahren aus der wissenschaft ist dass
es sich also das ist teilaspekte gibt es
ein sinnvoll das ist ein monitoring gibt
dass es nach verbesserungen gibt
das ist alles gut und zeigten ganz
kleinen weg auf das man aber sozusagen
das große ganze stimmt nicht und wenn
die summe der maßnahmen nicht ausreicht
um die klimaziele einzureichen stellen
wir fest dass das für uns kein guter
schritt ist wie wird es dann jetzt für
sie weiter gehen also machen sie jetzt
weiter mit den protesten ihren freitag
oder haben sie noch weitere pläne um da
eben gehört zu bekommen naja warten auf
der straße stehen wie wir letzte woche
freitag auf der straße werden diese
macht weiter druck der straße stehen und
wir setzen aber auch darauf dass eine
wache gesellschaft mit macht und
mitzieht und da wo sie eben kann
widerstand leistet auf der straße oder
in unternehmen etc
wie gesagt wir diese diese angelegenheit
davor und ist nun die frage der
klimakrise die frage des klimaschutzes
in deutschland ist eine so fundamentale
frage der brauch ist alles stimmen da
war es auch die kritik an aber auch die
leute die alle nichts damit am hut haben
weil es alle nunmal tangiert alle sind
gefragt sich einzubringen und damit das
aber erfolg haben kann braucht es jetzt
eine gesellschaft die in gewissermaßen
aufwacht und feststellt was gerade was
für ein skandal sie gerade erleben
auf politischer ebene mit uns gemeinsam
laut wird lösen aber das war jetzt der
letzte appell appell zusammen laut
werden das ist das was sie sich wünschen
das sind ihre forderung und ich bedanke
mich sehr dass sie sich heute für uns
zeit genommen haben und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei euch für die vielen
kommentare und fragen und würde mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr bei eurem nächsten
live stream auch dabei seit der findet
am donnerstag statt wie gewohnt um 20.30
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann klickt euch doch
vielleicht mal hier rein
da haben wir mit harald lesch über das
klima paket gesprochen oder ihr guckt
mal da das könnt ihr euch auch
interessieren da war volker quaschning
hier und hat mit uns darüber gesprochen
wie der klimawandel noch zu stoppen ist
oder ihr klickt mal da da könnt ihr den
neuen zdf- heute- youtube-kanal
abonnieren